[Music]
monica e riposi il impressi rooms with
the same high broadband deco di stan e
di questo volta
to mention decoder e chi no inside
d'action no deco this directive so nice
to be transposed into national everywhere e
in europa è di subìre il  iii the pride
task of every politician underhill ikea
sabaudi sector shooter juve rickli ali
we are a scintu transposed co del
national legislation so that will be
aware premi task a cantello we will
have
even il
pid long in the meantime national
rigoletto ken apply moody's in the
causes not for be there for most of the
scenes qui cè in the cut scenes candy
dan immediately so there are trionfo
titus armeni nice to this entry tool sui
cia furnì very  important for easy fiber
roll out the first one is the
possibility to call gest in part of the
territory re or territory and country
and to tweet itself flexible way with
flexible agreement and disease and
possibi  li di tekken b explodes veri
quickly and again the mistress and we
will not object of national regulator
budak 7 co investment plan b a the one
introdusse e new bike o operator witches
di consale onde operator di super edolo essa
selling quadro operators d'asti the
science  fiction off di hall se l'on.le
operator è né i cubi again and small
type of operation that covers numbero
factories thanks to the air now i could be
quite all'ars in about e country or
religion the actress the most important
thing  when you have such an operator des
corses true customers judo need
well yes say come show you need to be
sure that this operator e se le gamin
not to its own commercial division and the
knot canto however obligation a minor cost
of bills ora studi said on it  but
he sees the direction of travel and long
as this is made available
made available s commercial off the
rough there ok occorsi text pirri sono
hubble e bla bla bla batam in is not the
traditional typo regulation that  you
have seen in telecom steps from in di
hall consideration about marche power
witches but also power of course and
have incontro de customers il dio per
eto'o da sente control de castro nel
destino reason to apply e vi regulation
and very important 9th another one  isfor
dolls operator switch a del campetto per
eto'o si strofe commitments for instance
when the flying fi brains erta neri as
so deesis e possibility del re places di
traditional regulation e ne gann dos
commitment changes and currencies
vai di Regolado sam ed obligatory if
they  are better than any other
regulators luca so there are many to
handle stuhr che explode to make life
simplicio operators e for customers di
a2 points
we're very worried about that takes
around fiber di slogan we are looking
mormora di overall cost of delivering e
file  del network e non forzo dei due
noto statham in guarin comes to the
ground work really groundwork and rimini
tamin di katyn per mission un diliquidi
local autore  of hits eni show and beat of
guerre in europe north east da reptiles
cisco de coster and action directive that
exactly made for this is it has been
implement the wee dap sandown nel derby
terry wars in europe probable not
enough its we want to discuss here about
ubuntu silhouette her with udu e bit
more amin
io mai 6 abatesi slogan europe che ha
sin qui che discuss whether the problem
se gondry si whether the solution and
slim e b di scarca bout modernising
distretti in the next legislative cycle
we had done santin similar to for
microsoft deluded cod
now es simplified authors session pass
for microsoft berlin authors session a
single installation lean se providers
else if you ever it was possible two
industries aspect and hours dimension
could make the difference mine and back
of obligation for goldman sachs oli
license spectrum by  twenty five of
spectrum battenti tuenti hennequin to be
serious about his and above serve
another and megan spectrum dati store and of
bindi cyb  er photocall of open
infligge matt gross ttx for kant respect bit
amin sync in too much his spectrum
essentials or operators to the
fantasticks is like the row l'auto fi.gi
in combination fiber of which is very
much need to have in integral su una
band by unite spectrum my team his
the a we will make sud can of mayor and
applicable we have also simplified many
password regulation we are created the
same rules for consumers
giro however consumer protection we have
brand new set of tools for regulators to
apply in sé flexible way di hexis thing
rus life roosters amine del unico
european termination retro void
everytime fine saitech tv sex lies in
un fixing dos reis over all the
direction travel ace morrow  band
floorman moore high speed robyn moore
five morra file clr tapes del sud
what we are a nepi of ram in the text
politics compromise yukinobu andrè per
s  anta ap battaglini sparto see he can
create his own tweak tools compared to
sync expect coordination parties
insufficient etwas not what was our
origin proposal
and if you see amin nord scare in
un'industria bout
ma tu screen min sunmizer
tanti aboudi options fi.gi terp  roster maybe
the commission di star wars right to ask
for discipline mall coordination of air
force we will insist viva last
books times witness wiispeak indies
complexity ama 6 di 6 dia of creating
board the single market is one of those e
di hardcore dell'auto  banner
present here thirty indieframe proposes
intense legislation
the tool bodies and the tops of 9 pina prud which
cis for europe and near the record
gas norma will complain about armenia nuns doctors
the failure and which ebit you understood
news from a minimum must rwe set puddu amin
colletti  the milk of course di
istituisce un setup project with it now
i think we are in situation weekend
proudly say we have
marketing europe si colma anch  and guide
all digital borders the muba ground io
don rom in fiches
io che workshop favorite movie horror
football match of snow geoblogging free
flow warp his and characterists dove
single marker witches rado unique in the
world basic liam in you don't fight
another  year e o five hundred million
cities testis characteristics of ad
positive achievement witches 3 con
tape l over the world europe isti only
region of the world that can't stand
intense i weekends introduced regulation
about d age and the way they dalle artriti
boyardi only  larger in wish we have and
general data protection regulation del
gdp a we have against the world and in
particular european act of complex ixus
saces auto balance del right of rights
holder and direct auto balance users who
use copyright su copyright cruz are
data protection in ussr  copyright no
taxation frau di fico triste subject su
hicks gliali younicef ​​Regola is that
Europe exhibited the gold rules the
words with this  is something to be proud
or not it up to you to design ice in cui
di riso nabli plaut suo these are good
part of the story dell'esc parto the
story is that europe il tremendo
sull'independent when he comes to
technologies and disease and  problems
and tremendously legging behind when it
comes to investment in infrastruxure
test part one in we should be good
connects to the best
possible speed and quality past
weekend on it snow b della guide
connections so that for people kind of
dei think there fondamenta right away di
testi che e scopamento qui a boves to
remember cost and low tomorrow its di
operator a compared to se  spect web
dying bayless anne hurd 6 time we have
in economics ai golden shares some
science slowdown nor capital intensive
industry rescue telecom b watch
for iker foley on water weekend to his
dell'  investment the launch mind but spies
priority in mind
in front of such and social from the id henin
last front there of the economic
challenge politics ass.to hard will
win them the war crimes and much as
possible investment simple you are in
difficulty of industries
ad hong sik from home bureaucracy wish
directive by huawei order b and
reflection you don't look at industry and goes
che milling to di it and business model no
a sin dai nas in from pipes and carrier all
pipes aminatu lei da un fabric structure
and get this ain'  t outcome of this e
cambi e e 4 si fici horse table cas
close distant spect system of very
interesting amin the snow need tutu
collapse the value chain il gol
ramin in other business his eyes inc the
business and providing the network it
very very interesting one of  course
provider of cash flow arssu stenebo the
on stands are denis dadis continuous
often del prices will go down
bicos enia of the new browser
i test google dow amazed me somehow party
n faced with e  fa del fabric quality es
in every other products
amen coli di ma spire world one home one
is able to establish morderle scip2
equality and price a sint business or
providing high speed infrastruxure o
nixon e severi veri tre stint business
to be the border deceives much more
complex ue boksic st going on amin di
enterprise or the feature will lead and
sword of integrated solution that would
mix high speed computing cloud security
the network and his deliver probable s
package so this is e neri aware of
course and many of dell'arch cloud
provider life plus in the world al look
in more moore bat il ceneri hauer
telecom tradition telecom provider
related comfort
we were so this is clearly and in the
war alliance field place where the
hell is important buy from add ons in
telecom industries car dei waves
contrary and  saints to say what we will due
micro a me be les fauves giganti
production horrors already on tour lazio
icing last we will have to see a meno
gottlieb i  political direction ad enel
con bici non so a che non li give you
god is my very humble opinion to the
settlor in time for what it's worth e
6 set
we have three mega trend dei pini tutu
luperi carefully the first one is europe
nice to be  on the technological forefront
henin sanchi technologies artificial
intelligence super computing blog chen
cui arno kia dea we need to be make sure
that europe is
hoening  e
nell'ingeri felici work of arctico europe kenobi
dependent amin this is to risks and
probable not the rise in tuffo nella
van Sesso said the second element and the
link of the p2 this is a bossi chiuditi
demorde world becomes digital de mohr
debord cyber security  becomes edition
costs si soft course the week side e 9
digital society suo the one that
politicians a no more war focusing on
the issues a bossi  clarified security of
everything objects connects dobbs
security network
we have now foundation of di rousse
perhaps also follow in europe therefore in
ai asteriti del nord e cyber security
regulation cyber security act e pushes
st prude yesterday bale parlament
no we entering dilute a witches
certification standards working  with
industry making sure that the seas lo
label of european security achieve the
third trend is about securing the right
environment conditions for investing
indici l'economy isis prodi all velici
formi del soft di tut to have and large
market and well ramin customers qui c'  is
empowered and possible to action purchase
product services of internal market da
mansion we remember important and we are
just the beginning of the days wia
bolis barriers fa in country lotto to end
six components sabbath investment using
di aldridge instrument on we have a giro
p a legal  and local level to go
interaction that is best man friendly and
barmen and you said x  tend to shwe rai
started we will look very carefully
modiste total cost of the liver i fori
operator fuori sneijder roll out fiber
round round europe and try to understand
how much discosto delivery and related
to barriers retta e ips bureaucracy
station no b day
entrai tuel  minister I wait
[Applause]